CONVERSATION.
THANKS, JAKE.
>> ALL RIGHT, ANDERSON.
WELCOME TO CNN TONIGHT.
I'M JAKE TAPPER IN WASHINGTON.
TONIGHT WE ARE JUST TWO WEEKS
AWAY FROM THE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT MIDTERM ELECTIONS AND
I HAVE BEEN TALKING TO
STRATEGISTS AND POLLSTERS FROM
BOTH PARTIES TODAY TO TRY TO GET
A SENSE AND SHARE WITH YOU WHAT
THEY THINK THE LAY OF THE LAND
IS RIGHT NOW.
ALLOW ME TO BE YOUR GUIDE AS WE
TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT THEY THINK
IS GOING ON OUT THERE.
BECAUSE EARLIER THIS MONTH, YOU
MIGHT REMEMBER, WE TOLD YOU HOW
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S POLLSTER
COINED THIS ELECTION HEAD WINDS
VERSUS HEAD CASES.
THE HEAD WINDS IN HIS VIEW,
CHALLENGING THE DEMOCRATS.
MAJORITY DISAPPROVAL OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN, HIGH INFLATION,
POSSIBLE RECESSION AMONG OTHER
FACT FORCE.
THE HEAD CASES HINDERING
REPUBLICANS, WHAT REPUBLICAN
SENATE LEADER MITCH McCONNELL
REFERRED TO AS CANDIDATE QUALITY
ISSUES.
THAT'S REPUBLICAN CANDIDATES
WITH LIMITED APPEAL OR VARIOUS
SCANDALS, CREATING CHALLENGES IN
RACES THAT THEORETICALLY THEY
SHOULD BE RUNNING AWAY WITH.
BUT THOSE HEAD WIND, THEY TEEM
SEEM TO BE ACHANGING AND GETTING
STRONGER AND THE POLITICOS WHO
WHOM I SPOKE TO TODAY AGREE NOW
A MODEST RED WAVE AT THE VERY
LEAST SEEMS TO BE BUILDING.
BEST ESTIMATES PUT REPUBLICANS
AT PICKING UP 25 SEATS.
THEY ONLY NEED TO WIN FIVE TO
FLIP THE HOUSE FOR CONGRESSMAN
KEVIN McCARTHY TO COME HOUSE
SPEAKER KEVIN McCARTHY.
HOW WORRIED ARE DEMOCRATS?
JUST TODAY BIDEN DIRECTED THE
DEMOCRATIC COMMITTEE TO TRANSFER
ANOTHER $18 MILLION TO HELP
HOUSE AND SENATE DEMOCRATS IN
THEIR RACES.
THAT INCLUDE A HIGH PROFILE RACE
IN NEW YORK FEATURING THE HEAD
OF THE DEMOCRATIC CONGRESSIONAL
CAMPAIGN COMMITTEE, A MEMBER OF
HOUSE LIP.
THE DCCC IS SO WORRIED ABOUT IT
OWN CHAIRMAN, SEAN PATRICK
MALONEY, THAT THE DCCC IS
THROWING ANOTHER $600,000 IN THE
RACE TO DEFEND HIM.
THAT ALONE FOR AT DEMOCRATS IS
ALARMING.
BUT WHEN DEMOCRATS ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT HOUSE SEATS IN NEW
ENGLAND, THAT IS A FLASHING RED
LIGHT.
FIRST LADY JILL BIDEN HEADS TO
RHODE ISLAND TOMORROW TO HELP A
DEMOCRATIC HOUSE CANDIDATE
THERE.
VICE PRESIDENT KAMALA HARRIS
VISITED CONNECTICUT EARLIER THIS
MONTH TO HELP A HOUSE DEMOCRATIC
CANDIDATE THERE, AND REPUBLICANS
ARE REPORTEDLY NOW RECOMMITTING
MONEY IN NEW HAMPSHIRE TO TRY TO
UNSEAT DEMOCRATIC SENATOR MAGGIE
HASSAN.
CONTINUING OUR TRIP NOW THROUGH
THE POLITICAL LANDSCAPE, LET'S
GO VISIT MY HOME COMMONWEALTH OF
PENNSYLVANIA.
TONIGHT THE TWO SENATE
CANDIDATES IN THAT RACE SPAR IN
THE THEIR FIRST AND ONLY DEBATE.
DEMOCRATIC LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR
JOHN FETTERMAN VERSUS REPUBLICAN
CANDIDATE MEHMET OZ.
>> I'M ALSO HAVING TO TALK ABOUT
SOMETHING CALLED THE OZ RULE,
THAT IF HE'S ON TV, HE'S LYING.
>> JOHN FETTERMAN TAKES
EVERYTHING TO AN EXTREME, AND
THOSE EXTREME POSITIONS HURT US
ALL.
>> NOW, THIS RACE LOOKED LIKE A
SLAM DUNK VICTORY FOR FETTERMAN
EARLIER THIS SUMMER AND NOT JUST
BECAUSE AT 6'8", HE TOWERS OVER
DR. OZ.
>> PEOPLE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
LABEL ME MY ENTIRE LIFE.
I DO NOT LOOK LIKE A TYPICAL
POLITICIAN.
I DON'T EVEN LOOK LIKE A TYPICAL
PERSON.
>> SINCE THEN, THE POLLS HAVE
TIGHTENED.
THEY SEEM TO BE BASICALLY WITHIN
THE MARGIN OF ERROR RIGHT NOW.
AND WHILE OZ HAS BEEN OUT MEMED
ON SOCIAL MEDIA BY FETTERMAN,
WHO PAINTS THE LONG TIME NEW
JERSEY RESIDENT AS A PHONEY AND
A QUACK, FETTERMAN HAS BEEN HIT
WITH MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF
CAMPAIGN ADS ATTACKING HIM ON TV
FOR BEING SOFT ON CRIME.
>> JOHN FETTERMAN'S RECORD ON
CRIME IS CRAZY.
>> JOHN FETTERMAN SUPPORTS
DECRIMINALIZING DANGEROUS DRUGS
LIKE FENTANYL AND HEROIN.
>> FETTERMAN'S IDEAS ARE
RADICAL, DEADLY, AND WRONG.
>> AND FOR PENNSYLVANIANS AND
THOSE IN THE TRISTATE AREA YOU
WILL SOON LIKELY SEE MORE TV ADS
JUST LIKE THOSE, BECAUSE TODAY
THE TOP REPUBLICAN SUPERPACK
ANNOUNCED THEY'RE GOING TO THROW
$6 MILLION INTO THE RACE.
NOW IT'S POSSIBLE DR. OZ COULD
BECOME SENATOR OZ, EVEN THOUGH
HE HAS A NET NEGATIVE
FAVORABILITY RATING IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
MORE PEOPLE DISAPPROVE OF HIM
THERE THAN APPROVE OF HIM.
QUITE A BIG GAP AT THAT.
LET'S TURN WEST NOW.
LET'S GO FROM PENNSYLVANIA TO
AMERICA'S DAIRYLAND, IN A SENATE
RACE IN WHICH MOMENTUM SEEMED TO
SHIFT TOWARDS THE GOP, AGAIN
WORK REPUBLICANS ATTACKING THE
LIEUTENANT GOVERNOR MANDELA
BARNES FOR BEING SOFT ON CRIME.
A "WASHINGTON POST" ANALYSIS
FOUND REPUBLICANS SPENT TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS MORE
ATTACKING DEMOCRATS ON CRIME
THAN ON INFLATION.
NOW, JUST TWO MONTHS AGO,
DEMOCRATS WERE CONFIDENT THAT
BARNES WOULD BE ABLE TO KNOCK
OFF WISCONSIN SENATOR RON
JOHNSON.
NOW THE RACE IS A TOSSUP.
PEOPLE I SPOKE TO TODAY THINK
RON JOHNSON PROBABLY HAS A
SLIGHT EDGE, BUT THE DEMOCRATIC
FINGER POINTING HAS BEGUN.
>> THE NATIONAL PARTY TOTALLY
FAILED US, SO IT'S GOING TO COME
DOWN TO WISCONSIN DEMOCRATS.
PEOPLE ARE HITTING THEIR HEADS
AGAINST THE WALL.
HOW DID WE LET THIS HAPPEN?
>> OVER A THOUSAND MILES AWAY,
LET'S GO TO ARIZONA.
REPUBLICAN HEAVYWEIGHTS TRYING
TO BOOST BLAKE MASTERS AGAINST
MARK KELLY.
KELLY, IT IS BELIEVED, MAY HAVE
A SLIGHT EDGE, BUT THAT RACE,
TOO, IS TIGHTENING.
IN THE LAST TWO WEEKS, FORMER
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE AND
SENATOR RICK SCOTT OF FLORIDA,
THE HEAD OF THE REPUBLICAN
SENATE ARM HAS FLOWN IN TO
CAMPAIGN WITH MASTERS.
THE NEXT LEG IS TO NAVIGATE THE
ROADBLOCKS THAT STAND BETWEEN
DEMOCRATS AND ELECTORAL SUCCESS.
>> WHAT IS HAPPENED IN THE LAST
TWO MONTHS THAT HAS CHANGED THIS
RACE?
>> WELL, I THINK INFLATION.
I MEAN, EVERYBODY'S FEELING IT
IN THEIR POCKETBOOK.
>> THAT IS THE NUMBER ONE
CONCERN FOR AMERICANS RIGHT NOW
IN YET A NEW POLL FROM MONMOUTH
SAYS 63% OF AMERICANS BELIEVE
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS NOT PAYING
ENOUGH ATTENTION TO THE ISSUES
THAT MATTER MOST TO THEM.
THAT MAY BE PART OF THE REASON
WHY DEMOCRATS ARE ALSO STARTING
TO FACE STRUCTURAL PROBLEMS WITH
VARIOUS RACIAL MINORITIES,
GROUPS THAT THEY HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO RELY UPON FOR ELECTORAL
SUPPORT IN THE PAST -- BLACKS,
LATINOS, ASIAN AMERICANS,
PACIFIC ISLANDERS.
GROUPS THAT ARE STARTING SLOWLY
BUT SURELY TO PEEL AWAY FROM
AUTOMATICALLY SUPPORTING
DEMOCRATS.
ONE POLL SHOWS THAT HISPANICS'
SUPPORT FOR DEMOCRATS IN
CONGRESSIONAL RACES DROPPED BY
ABOUT 13 POINTS SINCE THE 2016
AND 2018 ELECTIONS.
NOW, 13 POINTS, THAT MIGHT NOT
SOUND LIKE MUCH TO YOU, BUT EP
IF JUST A SLIVER OF MINORITY
VOTERS PASSED A BALLOT FOR
REPUBLICANS OR STAY AT HOME,
THAT COULD BE IN THESE TIGHT
RACES ENOUGH TO HAND REPUBLICANS
A VICTORY.
AND VOTER ENTHUSIASM FOR
DEMOCRATS, AMONG DEMOCRATIC
GROUPS AND DEMOGRAPHICS, RIGHT
NOW THAT APPEARS A REAL
CHALLENGE, AS SENATOR BERNIE
SANDERS TOLD ME TWO DAYS AGO.
>> I AM WORRIED ABOUT THE LEVEL
OF VOTER TURNOUT AMONG YOUNG
PEOPLE BE WORKING PEOPLE WHO
WILL BE VOTING DEMOCRATIC.
I THINK WHAT WE'VE GOT TO DO IS
CONTRAST WHAT A STRONG PRO
WORKER DEMOCRATIC POSITION IS
WITH THE CORPORATE AGENDA OF THE
REPUBLICANS.
SO.
>> SO, THE HEAD WINDS ARE
DISCOURAGING THOSE VOTERS FROM
VOTING DEMOCRATIC, AND AMONG KEY
SWING VOTERS, DEMOCRATS WHO
CONTROL THE WHITE HOUSE, HOUSE,
AND SENATE, THEY'RE BEING HELD
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE STATE OF THE
NATION.
DEMOCRATS HAVE EVERYTHING --
EVERYTHING -- TO LOSE.
SO HERE IS WHERE ON OUR MIDTERMS
TOUR YOU WOULD EXPECTWELL BUMP
INTO THE FACE OF THE PARTY,
PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
NO ONE WOULD FAULT YOU FOR
ASSUMING BIDEN IS RIGHT NOW OUT
THERE BLITZING THE COUNTRY,
RALLYING IN EVERY SINGLE
BATTLEGROUND STATE ALONG WITH
BRUCE SPRINGSTEEN AND BON JOVI
AND JAY-Z TRYING TO PROTECT HIS
MAJORITY.
THE REALITY IS, HE'S NOT, NOT IN
PENNSYLVANIA WHERE THE FAMOUS
SON OF SCRANTON HAS ROOTS.
AS OF NOW, DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES
IN PENNSYLVANIA DO NOT SEEM TO
WANT HIM THERE, WHICH MAKE IT
ALL THE MORE CHALLENGING FOR
BIDEN AND HIS PARTY TO BUCK
HISTORICAL TRENDS.
BECAUSE HISTORY SHOWS THAT THE
PARTY IN POWER TENDS TO LOSE
SEATS IN THE MIDTERM ELECTIONS.
FOR GEORGE W. BUSH IN 2006, HE
TOOK A THUMPING.
>> THIS IS A CLOSE ELECTION.
IF YOU LOOK AT RACE BY RACE, IT
WAS CLOSE.
THE CUMULATIVE EFFECT, HOWEVER,
WAS NOT TOO CLOSE.
IT WAS A THUMPING.
>> FOR BARACK OBAMA IN 2010,
DESPITE STAR STUDDED RALLIES, HE
TOOK A SHELLACKING.
>> I'M NOT RECKING FOR EVERY
FUTURE PRESIDENT TO TAKE A
SHELLACKING LIKE I DID LAST
NIGHT.
>> A THUMPING, A SHELLACKING.
I'M NOT SURE WHAT GERUND
JOE BIDEN MIGHT BREAK OUT,
STOMPING PERHAPS.
BUT IF BIDEN ACKNOWLEDGES A
WALLOPING IT'S NOT AS IF IT
WOULD BE UNPRECEDENTED.
THE PAST IS NOT LOST WHEN IT
COMES TO SOMETHING ELSE
AS YOUR ELECTION GUIDE I HAVE TO
WARN YOU, WATCH OUT.
THIS IS UNCHARTERED TERRITORY.
FIRST ELECTION SINCE DONALD
TRUMP CONVINCED A HUGE SWATH OF
THE U.S. ELECTION SYSTEM IS
RIGGED.
IT'S A FALSE CHARGE, BUT IT LED
TO A BLOODY INSURRECTION, AND
THIS TIME AROUND WE'RE SEEING
BIG SIGNS OF POTENTIAL TROUBLE.
CANDIDATES IN KEY RACES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY CONTINUE TO LIE TO
VOTERS ABOUT THE 2020 ELECTION.
THESE ARE IN SOME CASES THE SAME
PEOPLE WHO WILL BE IN CHARGE OF
CERTIFYING THE RECOMMENDATION
RESULTS IF THEY WIN.
THE LIST INCLUDES SECRETARY OF
STATE CANDIDATES IN NEVADA.
IN ARIZONA, KARI LAKE.
THAT COULD BECOME A HUGE PROP IN
2024 IF THEY GET ELECTED AND
CONTINUE TO SQUARE ALLEGIANCE TO
TRUMP'S LIES INSTEAD OF THE U.S.
CONSTITUTION.
ANOTHER ISSUE NOW, NOT IN 2024
BUT NOW, THESE ALLEGATIONS OF
VOTER INTIMIDATION WE'RE
HEARING.
INTIMIDATION BY VIGILANTES.
LAST FRIDAY, TWO INDIVIDUALS
DRESS IN THE TACTICAL GEAR WERE
SPOTTED AT A BALLOT DROP BOX IN
MESA, ARIZONA.
ALSO IN THE GRAND CANYON STATE,
A GROUP CALLING ITSELF CLEAN
ELECTIONS USA, ACCUSED OF
STALKING BALLOT BOXES, TAKING
PHOTOS OF VOTERS' LICENSE
PLATES.
THIS IS IMPACTING MOSTLY, WE'RE
TOLD, LATINA VOTERS AND IN
PARTICULAR, THE ELDERLY.
SENIORS OFTEN PREFER A BALLOT
DROPOFF TO HAVING TO STAND IN
LONG LINES ACCORDING TO A
LAWSUIT FILED BY THOSE VOTERS.
YERKT CLEAN ACTIONS USA USED AT
LEAST ONE VOTER, PERHAPS YOUR
AVERAGE GRANDMA, OF BEING A
MULE.
A MULE IS A REFERENCE TO A
FRINGE VOTER FRAUD CONSPIRACY
THAT WAS AMPLIFIED IN THE LATEST
MAGA PROPAGANDA FILM, THE WIDELY
DISCREDITED, FACT-CHALLENGED
"2,000 MULES."
>> NOW WE COME TO THE MOST
IMPORTANT QUESTION OF ALL -- WAS
THE NAG ANY ATTITUDE OF VOTE
TRAFFICKING ENOUGH TO TIP THE
BALANCE IN THE 2020 PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION?
>> IT'S NOT A LEAP TO SAY THIS
WOULD HAVE MADE A DIFFERENCE.
>> IT'S NOT A LEAP, IT'S JUST A
LIE.
IT'S JUST A HUGE LIE.
HOW FULL OF CRAP IS IT?
WELL, THEY HAD TO PULL THE "2000
MULES" BOOK BEFORE IT WENT ON
SALE, REWRITE IT PRESUMABLY TO
AVOID LEGAL ACTION.
IN THE 2020 ELECTION AND 2022
MIDTERMS, THERE IS NO CREDIBLE
EVIDENCE OF MULES.
THERE IS CREDIBLE EVIDENCE OF
JACKASSS.
NOW, THIS IS JUST WHAT THE
TERRAIN LOOK LIKE RIGHT NOW, AND
IT IS HARD TO KNOW WHAT IT ALL
MIGHT MEAN.
THE U.S. IS ALSO CURRENTLY
SEEING RECORD NUMBERS FOR EARLY
VOTING.
MORE THAN 9 MILLION AMERICANS
HAVE ALREADY CAST THEIR BALLOTS.
IS THAT GOOD FOR DEMOCRATS?
IS IT GOOD FOR REPUBLICANS?
ONE THING WE CAN ASSERT IS IT'S
GOOD FOR DEMOCRACY.
IT'S GOOD FOR THE REPUBLIC.
THERE IS SOMETHING MOTIVATING
AMERICANS TO DROP WHAT THEY'RE
DOING, STAND IN LINE, AND
PARTICIPATE IN A MIDTERM
ELECTION.
REGARDLESS OF WHAT EXPERTS ARE
PREDICTING RIGHT NOW, WHETHER
THEY'RE RELYING ON POLLING OR
TURN